c'est vrai que j'adore rire et blaguer
mais y'a des moments il faut savoir être
sérieux surtout quand il s'agit du
cancer du sein
si vous êtes une femme de plus de 50 ans
vous allez recevoir une aide pour faire
dépister
prenez rendez vous vous avez peut-être
vu cette publicité diffusée en ce moment
nagui qui se prononcent pour le
dépistage du cancer du sein
une campagne nationale pour inciter les
femmes entre 50 et 74 ans a bénéficié du
dépistage gratuit et sur le terrain une
mobilisation également locales comme ici
à trappes
avec l'opération des parapluies rose on
invite les femmes à se faire dépister
parce qu'en fait on s'aperçoit qu'en
dans les yvelines
on est un département où 41 % seulement
des femmes participent à ce dépistage
organisé
donc il ya des gens qui sont réticents
irak il y en a qui ont peur parce que le
cancer est un mot qui fait peur
donc nous on essaye simplement de
dédramatiser et de leur dire que
justement avec le avec le dépistage
c'est pas forcément la maladie cc c'est
justement en s'y prenant parfois tôt
qu'un cancer et déplie cancer est
dépisté tôt pour mieux on le soigne des
comédiens sont donc venus raconter des
histoires pour faire passer un seul
message détecté tôt 90% des cancers du
sein sont guéris avec près de cinquante
trois mille nouveaux cas chaque année le
cancer du sein est le cancer le plus
fréquent chez la femme dans les yvelines
un centre de coordination est basé au
chesnay